[موسيقى]
تخيل أنك قادر على النوم في
أي مكان تريده في أي وقت تريده ،
يقول زيف دائمًا إنه يستطيع فعل الأمرين معًا ،
لكن هذا البالغ من العمر 33 عامًا حاصل على درجة الدكتوراه في
العلوم الإدراكية العصبية وقد أمضى
سنوات في دراسة كيفية عمل أدمغتنا وهو
يعرف بعضًا من  نحن لسنا محظوظين جدًا ،
فهناك الكثير من الأشخاص الذين يعانون من
النوم بعد النوم ويعانون أكثر من سوء
نوعية النوم بسبب شريك الشخير
أو وجود طفل حديث الولادة يستيقظ
كل ثلاث ساعات.
ساعدني
هناك ولكن ما يمكن أن يفعله هو مساعدتك
على فهم سلوكيات النوم بشكل أفضل كم من الوقت
تنام ومقدار ما تقذفه
وتتجاوز ذلك ، ربما ستحتاج إلى
شيء أكثر تعقيدًا من جهاز
تعقب يتم شراؤه من المتجر اليوم ، فهو
حل رائع لقياس النوم  في
مستوى العافية ،
جميع أنواع مراتب الساعات ، ولكن عندما
ترغب في قياس جميع
جوانب النوم
هنا ، لديك فجوة
ويعتقد بيرمان أن هذا الجهاز يمكن أن
يملأ تلك الفجوة مثل
أداة المساعدة على النوم.  تم تزويد جهاز cker
بعشرات المستشعرات الصغيرة التي تلتقط
النشاط الكهربائي في الجسم أثناء
نومك ، وترسل البيانات مباشرة إلى
بيانات الجهاز الذكي مثل نشاط العضلات
وحركة العين وحتى موجات الدماغ.
استخدمه في المنزل بنفسك
مقابل عُشر تكلفة دراسة النوم الاحترافية ،
يقول بيرمان
إن المتتبع هو 10 سنوات في
طور الإعداد ، والسبب في أن بيرمان شارك في تأسيس
شركته الناشئة في إسرائيل في عام 2020
حتى مع الاهتمام المتزايد بالنوم هو
الدرجة الطبية
اختبار نومك لا يزال سوقًا متخصصًا نسبيًا ،
بدأنا نفهم أن النوم
هو منجم ذهب لفهم
صحتنا ، يمكن أن تساعد البيانات الأفضل
الباحثين الطبيين وليس فقط أولئك الذين يدرسون
النوم يقول بيرمان أنه يمكننا تحديد
كل من اضطرابات النوم
ولكن أيضًا أنماط النوم  التي تتعلق
باضطرابات أخرى ولكن بالنسبة للعديد من
أدوات النوم الجديدة في السوق ،
تظل الدقة صعبة إثبات قول الخبراء
لأنها حقًا
ج  omplex لتحديد مرحلة
النوم والحركة داخل وخارج
المراحل المختلفة ، لذا فإن أفضل طريقة
للشركات للقيام بذلك هي الشراكة
مع العلماء للتأكد من أن
الخوارزميات الخاصة بهم تسجل النوم بشكل
صحيح وتعطي المعلومات للمستهلكين
يقول بيرمان إن تقنيته
يتم اختبارها حاليًا من قبل باحثين مستقلين
للتحقق من صحتها ،
فإنها لا تزال بحاجة إلى موافقة إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) ، ولكن إذا
سارت الأمور على ما يرام ، فقد يكون هذا المتتبع في
السوق بحلول عام 2023. جزء من نشاطنا الآن
هو توفير النظام لجميع أنواع
الباحثين  العثور على أنماط جديدة أثناء
النوم على المدى الطويل يمكن أن تساعدنا
جميعًا في الغفوة لفترة أطول قليلاً